[Musique]
stopa
stop salut la
compagnie attendez TR filles une épouse
il manque une chose mais quoi JEE il est
là mon tout
petit je sais que tu l'aimes ton papa
Disle vas-y papa
papa bien sûr qu'il t'aime c'est jusquà
son âge il le montre pas sur son visage
il le montre pas dans ses gestes un gros
junior
auomination j'ai à vous parler Grou
votre famille est en danger
qu Maxime Le malâ s'est évadé de prison
je reviens me venger
Grou on doit vous amener dans un endroit
sûr il y a un distributeur je vaisê trop
bien ici
le principal dans un cambriolage c'est
d'être conscient du danger
potentiel je me suis
anesés
[Musique]
non
quoi
cé
TR bito h
[Musique]
mercian pas une
épaule